like throughout your career you've been
extremely active like if we don't have a
mozzie album will have a collab project
with you and gun player you ensue or you
I'm not gotta stay lit man this will be
in F oh yeah like I feel like that that
you know just your activity has a lot of
a lot to do with your success right like
sure what what are some see um some some
advice you would give to independent
artists cuz I feel like you've been
building this for so long but like I've
noticed like I'm like yo this guy don't
give fans like a chance to forget like
he's on top he's on the neck like
consistency is key consistency is key
and um you know know who your market is
and reciprocate the love make sure you
give back man as much as you receive
straight-up like the smallest things in
the world it go a long way with the
fanbase just imagine you having an
unconditional love for an artist and you
push up owning and he stiff-armed you
Frank you gonna feel some type of way
you might not feel the same way you felt
about that artists again
you feel me so you know I see the love I
recognize the love and I reciprocate it
when I see it I make sure you know I
dish out their same energy I make sure I
make sure I treat them you know I treat
them like like I feel if it was the
other way around if I was the fan and
this was somebody I listen to and how
would I want to be you know treated in
this situation so even when I'm tired
even when I'm exhausted
I'm with my daughters and don't feel
like doing this [ __ ] I'm tired of taking
pictures
I'm tired of signing [ __ ] watch out
right fill me this is me time my time I
still go out my way still go out my way
and make sure you know that they leave
satisfied and it's work for me it's
benefited me man it's worked for me and
the crazy part about it is it's not it's
not hard or it's not a task when when
you genuine about it when you genuinely
felt like that and I'm saying same thing
with this music it don't feel like work
when you're
passionate about this this is this is I
do this for free I would love to come
through this interview am saying this is
this is me this without that's what I
signed up for I've been waiting on this
day I pray for this day I set on a bunk
and pray for this so now that I'm here
man I embrace it wholeheartedly and you
know if anything I do man I give it my
all so I just I say Kate stay stay
consistent and you know just reciprocate
the love man even I don't care how small
it is
if there's somebody reposting your [ __ ]
on instagram if it's somebody a DJ
shouting you out man on the radio out of
nowhere it's made sure you know you you
you get it love right back and you build
your build on top of that that's
something to build on you